so thank you everyone my name is David
Smith and I'm a developer Advocate at
Microsoft and if you've ever given a
tutorial using r or just tried to share
our code with other people and gotten
these kind of responses then this talk
is for you now you might get these kind
of reactions because somebody didn't
read the setup instructions or installed
the wrong version of R and so your code
doesn't work whether using a different
operating system than you expect or just
using an old laptop that can't cope with
the data and the code that you've
provided you can resolve all these
issues by running in something called
GitHub code spaces so let's see how this
works I've got here a repository which
you can find on GitHub it has everything
you need to recreate what I'm showing
you right here but one of the things
that it does include is a DOT Dev
container folder and that is the magic
that allows you to click on that code
button directly in GitHub and then run
the code within code spaces now this is
running in real time it takes about 10
or 20 seconds what GitHub is doing right
here is setting up a code space kind of
like a little virtual machine that has
the version of r that I specified
installs all the r package versions that
I specified it also installs python my
data my code everything is all right
there ready for anybody who clicks on
their button to get exactly in the
environment that I intended for somebody
to run my code within so once that code
space launches in just a couple of
seconds what we'll see is a web
interface that looks much like Visual
Studio code and in fact this is Visual
Studio code running directly within the
browser and I can do all the usual
things like browsing within my file
system that comes from my repository
this is actually a tutorial that comes
from a collection provided by Microsoft
including a jupyter notebook which is to
teach somebody how to do data
exploration using R so this notebook has
popped up directly within Visual Studio
code and I can interact with it as you
would any other notebook like I can run
this cell right here and the surprising
thing is it runs without any errors
without any setup because all those pack
packages are already pre-installed
within the code space so your
participants can then interact with the
notebook run the code here's a tidy
verse function which is Reading in a
data file and showing in the first few
lines it's a very very natural
experience regardless what kind of
laptop that they brought to the workshop
with them
but what if you wanted to run your
Workshop within rstudio instead of
Visual Studio code that's easy too
because we have our studio server
installed within this code space just
need to go to the ports tab in Visual
Studio code and that launches our studio
server directly within my browser so
this is the same as our studio on the
desktop just running on a browser and I
can use that to open files and again I'm
going to open a file for my repository
they happen to live in the workspaces
folder when it's running on the server
then I browse through that and this time
let's grab an arm markdown document
instead so we can see how that works
within code spaces there we have our
markdown documents and we can just use
the usual net function within rstudio to
knit it to HTML and we can see our
output really quickly because it's
running on a machine with lots of ram
lots of CPU so these computations happen
nice and fast this is all thanks to the
menu the magic rather of Dev containers
which is a standardized way of setting
up a container for interactive use like
this you saw that Dev container 4 order
in my repository that's where I
specified the r versions the packages
and everything else that I needed to
give the same experience for every user
that interacts with my repo Dev
containers by the way are 100 open
source technology there is a command
line interface so you can integrate
those Dev containers into any
application not just GitHub and you can
find lots of information about them at
containers.dev but just to give you a
little bit of a flavor of how that works
if you're familiar with containers
you'll know about Docker files where you
can specify the software that gets
installed into that container in this
particular case I'm grabbing a pre-built
container from The Rocker project an
awesome project providing containers for
ah I chose the version of R in this case
it's grabbing the latest 4.x version so
I got the very newest 4.2.1 for that
particular example and I'm installing a
bunch of packages into that container as
well there's another file that lets you
configure Visual Studio code set some
options if people are using that editor
and you can also specify commands to run
at the beginning of the container like
starting the rstudio server which is how
we got that to work so in summary if you
want to do a tutorial or share some code
just create a GitHub repo as you always
do put all your scripts data notebooks
and instructions into there but then set
it up as a Dev container so that all the
software to run your code is fixed and
ready for anybody to use simply by
clicking on that run in GitHub code
spaces button directly in GitHub now
GitHub code spaces is only available
right now within GitHub Enterprise and
GitHub education if your participants
don't have access to code spaces today
they can run out locally using visual
studio code and I have another talk
which shows you how that works which you
can't quite see but you can find that
link directly on my GitHub repository
that you see on your screen right there
with everything you need to make all
this work for you thank you
foreign
[Music]